mal joué c'est tuer la plupart des
enfants qui abusent de leurs consoles
sont plus agressifs et renfermé les jeux
vidéo n'apporte rien lise abrutissent et
rendent violent
voici une phrase qui fait partie de
l'histoire ancienne de nos jours le jeu
vidéo est partout dans le sport dans
l'armée dans l'éducation et même tenez
vous bien dans la recherche scientifique
alors évidemment il ne s'agit pas de
taper un call of au milieu des tubes à
essai mais plutôt de jeu avec des
communautés qui ont eu un impact réel
alors voyons voir si manette en main
vous deviendrez le grand scientifique de
demain à et puisqu'on parle de jeux
vidéo et de science on vous offre ce
super télescope pour observer les
étoiles lointaines le gagner c'est tout
simple il vous suffira juste de jouer
alors ce mobile d'un jeu mobile gratuit
où tu as des héros tu montes une armée
en utilisant au mieux leurs compétences
puis tu part à la conquête du monde
tu peut allier avec tes amis et brûlé
des châteaux ennemis capturés les
patrons exigé une rançon
sinon exécution le jeu est rempli de
champion super stylé avec chacun leurs
compétences uniques
tu peux même incarner les chevaliers du
zodiaque le partenariat est improbable
mais oui tu peut débloquer cia et il est
juste trop fort et les cadeaux alors eh
bien le télescope est à gagner
directement dans le jeu tu as juste à
utiliser le lien en descriptions pour
télécharger le jeu gratuitement sur
mantes le niveau de ton château et à
chaque fois tu peux tourner la roue de
la fortune
de plus les sept premiers jours de
l'installation tous les participants
recevront des tonnes de cadeaux lors du
mobile le lien est dans la description
dans le jeu vidéo part à la conquête de
l'espace
comment fait-on pour trouver une
nouvelle planète pas avec un simple
télescope en tout cas les plus gros
peuvent vous permettre de voir cette
urne à la limite ce de la nasa peut vous
permettre de voir plus ton mais de
manière très très flou et ça va pas plus
loin
non les planètes distante se détecte en
observant les étoiles si une planète
passe devant selon comment elle va
modifier la luminosité de l'étoile on
peut déterminer
l'un d'eux caractéristiques mais tout ça
mais ça fait beaucoup de données à
analyser et les ordinateurs ne sont pas
encore au point pour le faire de façon
autonome
c'est là que va aider eve online un jeu
multijoueur d'exploration spatiale avec
le projet discovery ils se sont associés
à l'observatoire de genève et michel
meyer
un astrophysicien nobélisé pour analyser
des données de luminosité via le jeu
vidéo
ils se sont concentrés sur la mission du
télescope spatial korotki en 2013
arrivé à son terme avec 32 exoplanètes
découvertes
mais durant ces sept ans en orbite corps
ott a récolté des données beaucoup de
données près de 160 mille courbe de
lumière
ça aurait demandé des années de travail
pour tous traités même pour une
intelligence artificielle qui je
rappelle à l'époque n'était pas tout à
fait au top et c'est là que les joueurs
peuvent participer dans le jeu comme par
hasard se trouve un pnj nommé michel
meyer qui explique justement aux joueurs
comment analyser ces données une fois le
tuto terminé au travail vous verrez à
l'écran une courbe de luminosité d'une
étoile sur 28 jours sur ce graphe vous
devez identifier les moments où elles
chutent
vous pouvez même analysé la période de
rotation trouver des informations sur
leurs beats et l'atmosphère grâce aux
données une fois l'analyse fini le jeu
vous récompensera avec quelques
ressources in game pour votre travail et
en deux ans et près de 230 millions d'
analyse de courbe de lumière qui ont été
effectués par les joueurs
de quoi faire économiser aux
scientifiques des dizaines d'années de
travail et les efforts ont porté leurs
fruits au moins pour détecter des bugs
et des faux positifs
c'est à dire des détections erronée dans
les données ce qui est primordial pour
les améliorer dans le futur les joueurs
ont tout de même découvert deux
candidats d'exoplanètes nommé pour le
moment inutile de rêver il n'y aura pas
de planète
eve odinius la nomenclature est très
stricte ça sera un truc avec plein de
lettres et plein de chiffres
un deuxième exemple intéressant c'est
celui de elite dangerous le jeu est
connu pour son obsession scientifique
vous pouvez vous balader dans plus de
400 milliards de systèmes générées par
ordinateur à partir de calculs
astronomiques réaliste
chaque planète a un coeur et une
atmosphère alex sa densité ou sa
composition chimique
ça va jusqu'à la brillance de son étoile
c'est comme dans la vraie vie
autant vous dire que c'est le terrain
d'expérience pour les jeunes
astrophysiciens ils ont créé le canal
research group qui leur permet
d'appliquer leur travail de thèse
directement dans le jeu et d'aller
observer les planètes qu'ils ont trouvé
bien de vraies études scientifiques et
statistiques qui sont donnés c'est juste
dingue et les développeurs s'en amuse en
lançant deux
entre énigmes scientifiques comme des
codes extraterrestre intercepté dans
l'espace qui oblige à des calculs type
nasa pour trouver leur provenance
un véritable entraînement pour nos
astrophysiciens en herbe si un jour on
venait à intercepter pour de vrai un tel
message dans le jeu vidéo contribue à la
médecine
il y a dans votre corps l'un des plus
grands mystères de la science une énigme
qui a fait s'arracher les cheveux à tous
les physiciens moléculaire on parle du
repliement des protéines tout dans votre
corps et protéines votre sang le
mouvement de vos muscles votre adn les
maladies les médicaments arriver à créer
des protéines sur mesure leur donner la
forme qu'on veut ça serait la clé pour
pouvoir tout guérir voire entièrement
modifié votre corps pour nous donner de
nouvelles capacités
ça c'est pour l'heure impossible les
protéines sont comme des puzzles que
vous voyez sur youtube
on ne sait pas prédire comment elles se
replient hop tu bouges un petit atom ici
la nouvelle protéine prend une forme que
tu ne voulais pas qu'elle prenne pour
vous donner un exemple un simple
peptides constitué de seulement cinq
acides aminés peut se replier en plus de
100 milliards de structures potentielles
parvenir à trouver la bonne structure
est donc un défi titanesque et c'est là
que va aider le jeu foldit
l'objectif de ce jeu et de plier le plus
parfaitement possible les structures des
protéines sélectionné à l'aide des
outils fournis dans le jeu mais il faut
faire attention
une protéine replié de manière
incorrecte peut être inactive dans le
meilleur des cas toxiques dans le pire
les solutions les plus performantes sont
ensuite envoyées et analysé par les
chercheurs qui détermine si les
molécules trouvé par les joueurs peuvent
être utilisés et c'est un succès la
version bêta publique de foldit publié
en mai 2008 compte près de 240 mille
joueurs inscrits une communauté capable
de faire des miracles
et c'est notamment le cas en 2011
l'équipe contender un petit groupe de
quinze très bon joueur s'est penché sur
un problème sur lesquelles la communauté
scientifique buts et depuis 13 ans la
structure cristalline d'une enzyme liées
aux délits h
il n'aura fallu que trois semaines à
l'équipe pour trouver la solution qui
fournit de nouvelles perspectives pour
la conception de médicaments pour lutter
contre le sida ne prouesse qui leur a
valu d'avoir leur pseudo cité dans un
article de la prestigieuse revue
scientifique nature's ce n'est pas le
seul jeu qui a aidé au pliage de
molécules il ya aussi eterna
un défi tout aussi ambitieux puisque on
s'attaque à la rn une molécule proche de
l'adn un joueur se voit présenter une
forme cible dans laquelle un brin
d'aillet rennes doit se replier
il doit donc manipuler la séquence de
nucléotides pour permettre la liaison
avec la cible et c'est une tâche
complexe lebrun doit être exactement
dans la bonne forme
un peu comme dans une serrure inc les
jeunes n'avaient pas la bonne clé ça ne
marche pas avec ses 250 mille joueurs
inscrits et terna réussi à faire
développer un diagnostic de la
tuberculose qui est maintenant en phase
de tests sur des patients
cependant ces belles histoires touchent
à leur fin avec le développement des
intelligences artificielles récemment
dit mind a créé alpha fold une ia qui
permettrait de plier des molécules aussi
bien voire mieux que les joueurs je vous
rassure néanmoins les joueurs humains
gardent leur utilité dans les deux
derniers jeux médicaux dont on va parler
le premier c'est plein tube jeans in
space avec ses 400 mille téléchargements
ici c'est de l'analyse de données
génétiques ou le savez peut-être votre
adn est une série de quatre nucléotides
représenté par les lettres tcg et chacun
des gènes de votre corps est une suite
de milliers de ces lettres
l'idée est donc de trouver une suite de
nucléotides connu indiquant la présence
de cancers dans le jeu vaut
cartographier votre itinéraire spatiale
une modélisation des données génétiques
des patients vous devez faire en sorte
de récupérer le plus d'éléments alpha
qui représente les séquences responsable
du cancer tout en évitant les astéroïdes
sur votre chemin
tout cela a permis d'analyser près de 5
millions de boue de données ce qui
correspond au génome de 1981 patients
chacun vérifier 50 fois pour sa
précision
le deuxième je sais highwire 250 me
power grâce à lui on peut participer à
la cartographie de la rétine et d'une
partie du système nerveux central
c'est un gros morceau 1,81 milliard de
neurones connecter un dédale
interminable de connexions nerveuses
il faut des dizaines d'heures à un seul
neuroscientifique pour reconstruire une
unique cellule nos complexité
insurmontable à moins d'avoir le jeu
concrètement le joueur reçoit un cube
avec une branche neuronale partiellement
reconstruite par unia il doit poursuivre
le travail de celle ci en colorant les
parties manquantes sur une série de
photos en 2d
à chaque fois qu'une amélioration et
réaliser des segmentations générés par
l'ia sont ajoutés au travail du joueur
sur le cube en 3d alors j'ai joué c'est
plus facile que ça en a l'air mais
c'était pas le giga fun non plus reste
que ce gameplay aide les chercheurs à
modéliser les circuits de traitement de
l'information dans le cerveau ça
entraîne des ja afin de maps et seul le
cerveau et détecter les erreurs de
connexion qui engendre des troubles
comme la schizophrénie
si vous cherchez à aider la science de
façon plus fun vous pouvez toujours
jouer à bordeaux lens 3 entre deux
expéditions sur des palettes où vous
tirer sur tout ce qui bouge
vous pouvez participer aux mini jeux
borderlands signs ça permet d'entraîner
une intelligence artificielle à éliminer
les erreurs lors de l'organisation et de
l'analyse des séquences génétiques de
bactéries dans les selles humaine oui
dans le caca le pire c'est pas une
blague c'est même un franc succès 1,6
million de joueurs différents ont résolu
au moins une seule tâche pour un total
collectif de 63,2 millions dhs énigme
résolue
une initiative d'une taille rarement
égalée dans le jeu vidéo pour un sujet
plus que loufoque
quand le jeu vidéo permet d'étudier les
pandémies 2020 cette année-là l'humanité
s'en souviendra alors que l'europe se
pensait épargner des grandes pandémies
aux millions de morts des siècles
précédents
la nature nous a rappelé l'importance
des recherches sur le sujet il ya quinze
ans de cela en 2005
l'ambiance n'était pas la même la grippe
h1n1 de 2009 n'était pas encore là il y
avait bien eu le strass mais bon c'était
700 morts quasi exclusivement camps
nazis
c'est pour ça qu'à cette date une
pandémie particulière a fait beaucoup
parler d'elle
l'épidémie du sang corrompus dans world
of warcraft le sens qu'on pût est un
sort utilisé par un boss qui peut
s'infecter te faire perdre de la vie et
se transmettre aux autres joueurs qui
combattent le boss avec toi bon
normalement à la sortie du nouvion tout
le monde est automatiquement guéri et on
en parle plus sauf que les programmeurs
avait oublié quelque chose
les animaux qui t'accompagne et les pets
eux ils ne sont pas guéris à la sortie
du donjon mais continue de transmettre
le sort aux joueurs à proximité une fois
arrivé dans une grande île
ça a été un berry table carnage une
pandémie mondiale dans un monde virtuel
ce qui a intéressé les chercheurs c'est
les similitudes entre cette endémie
virtuel et les épidémies de sras ce qui
venait de se passer
en effet dans notre jeu on peut
distinguer quatre groupes
les familiers à l'origine de la pandémie
qui sont porteurs sains les joueurs de
petit niveau qui sont des personnes à
risque les joueurs de haut niveau
représentant une personne en bonne santé
pouvant contaminer énormément de joueurs
et enfin les pnj à la fois porteur sain
et super contaminateur puisque tous les
joueurs vont commercer avec eux des
catégories qui se rapproche de la
réalité est encore constaté aujourd'hui
avec la pandémie de kobe 19
cependant l'étude de la propagation de
la pandémie a ses limites en effet dans
le jeu pas de vaccin disponibles pour
combattre la maladie et surtout bas on
peut ressusciter
et justement ce facteur a eu un rôle
très important dans la gravité de
l'épidémie
dès que les joueurs réapparaissent ils
sont de nouveau contaminé rendant
l'épidémie interminable dans la réalité
cette épidémie se serait arrêté dès lé
même relativement rapidement en plus par
manque de personnes a contaminé en
raison de sa létalité
le deuxième phénomène analysé et le
comportement des gens passent à une
telle pandémie
encore une fois ce n'est qu'un jeu mais
beaucoup de joueurs ont pris la pandémie
très au sérieux comme on l'a vu
récemment il y a une volonté de fuir les
zones contaminées
la mise en place de quarantaine et
confinement jamais entièrement respectée
car les joueurs veulent continuer de
faire des affaires et de jouer mais il
ya plusieurs comportements inattendus de
la part des joueurs comme la curiosité
en effet certains joueurs se précipiter
dans la zone infectée pour être témoins
de l'affection et de la mare de cadavres
qui jonchaient les rues pour ensuite
repartir une démonstration de plus de la
curiosité morbide de l'homme qui cette
fois ramène la maladie dans les
nouvelles zones et si certains pensent
que les jeux vidéo sont un bon moyen
d'étudier des épidémies il y a des
divergences d'opinions au sein de la
communauté scientifique
cela n'a pas empêché beaucoup de
chercheurs de dépoussiérer leurs
recherches quand la copie de 10,9 est
arrivé pour voir ce qui pouvait en tirer
cependant le lien entre les jeux vidéo
et les pandémies ne se limite pas à la
recherche
ils ont aussi un autre rôle important
l'information cela c'est
particulièrement vu en 2015 avec
l'épidémie d'ebola james vaughan le
développeur derrière plague inc célèbre
jeu ou votre objectif est d'exterminer
les humains au contrôle d'une maladie a
déclaré qu'en octobre
à l'époque où la couverture médiatique
des mollahs était à son apogée
les téléchargements de son jeu avait
augmenté de près de 50% en deux semaines
nombreux joueurs avaient même appelé
leur maladie ebola que ce soit par
fascination morbide pour l'actualité ou
par mauvaise plaisanterie blagging
semble également intéresser les
professionnels de l'épidémie vaughan a
été invité à visiter le site ici et a
donné une conférence afin de déterminer
comment le jeu pouvait être utilisé pour
sensibiliser le public à la transmission
des maladies
n'oubliez pas qu'on vous offre ce
superbe télescope avec leur mobile il
suffit de cliquer juste sur le lien en
descriptions et de plus tous les
nouveaux participants recevront des
tonnes de cadeaux les sept premiers
jours de suite quand vous étiez petit
vous avez forcément appris la vie avec
des jeux comme adibou ou pour les plus
âgés les chevaliers de baphomet et
aujourd'hui encore avec l'école à la
maison du au confinement
les développeurs se surpassent pour vous
amener dans cet univers d'apprentissage
infinie dernièrement au world et le jeu
ludo-éducatif français dont tout le
monde pas puisque les enfants ils
passent un temps fou
après on peut les comprendre le jeu
n'est pas dégueu il y à un monde ouvert
et les gratuits ils ont même implémenter
une intelligence artificielle qui va
adapter le niveau du jeu selon sa
progression vous l'avez compris science
et jeux vidéo sont liés je ne pense pas
que ça va rassurer votre maman parce que
sur call of duty à part apprendre des
insultes en russe
vous rendez pas le monde meilleur saut
casse au casque à viet se cache au
cachot cabaye est ce nom faut pas
déconner mais bon pour peu que vous
jouiez ou jeu dont on a parlé derrière
son clavier vos clics peuvent compter
même si ces invisibles à votre échelle
l'union fait la force
le jeu vidéo pourrait bien devenir le
moteur de la science du futur
[Musique]
il